[Music]
midway between orlando and miami on
florida's atlantic coast lies the small
town of fort pierce
home to the beachfront inn and inlet
owner brian paul
opened it in 2012 after running his
family's successful local fish market
with his brother my job before the inlet
was the the ceo the head of my dad's
fish market
my dad ran a business like a uh a real
leader he had
so many friends
pillared the community everybody loved
them and i always knew as a child i
wanted to have my own
place
[Music]
i think brian has a lot of schooling
under his belt i'm not exactly sure that
he has any hotel experience
brian as an owner is
physically here sometimes
he's just like kind of wanders around
brian is a little too easygoing if it
was me i'd have my hands nose eyes and
ears and everything and
i don't see
him doing that
brian definitely has a lot of friends at
work here some of which have taken
advantage of him in the past
i believe that
chef ben probably has taken most
advantage of him
i want a beer
oh we're having a tasty beer tonight
boys yeah
ben is a uh an awesome guy i've known
him forever we've been friends forever i
give him plenty of space i help him
whatever he needs but i don't muddle in
his affairs down there
i think that the issue here has been our
lack of consistency with our food and i
mean that directly has to be attributed
to the executive chef you know his name
is ben
i feel like the inlet and the beachfront
both back direction we're trying to be
too many things at once a nightclub a
bar a restaurant a hotel a wedding venue
a concert venue a place to do your
christmas party at i mean
ah
the military secret we have some guests
and employees who can holler until
the wee hours of the morning and that's
out of control that's got to stop it's
bad for business
brian has to refund hotel guest money
because of the noise complaints
[Music]
i think this place has so much potential
and so much to offer we don't want to
see it fail we don't want to see brian
fail he definitely needs to step up and
help us all out to help him
he needs to grab those reins and start
start seeing
the damage that's happening and start
fixing it
today i'm in the beautiful coastal town
of fort pierce florida just looking
around you're surrounded by stunning
beaches marina's full of deep-sea
fishing boats this place
is gorgeous
[Music]
look at this place
it looks like the hotel's closed down
hello
anybody in welcome
how are you
i'm veron dee thank you first name is
liza liza good to see you how are you
doing today whose is this
the boss man caught it and where's the
other half gone maybe they ate
a pair of shoes
i couldn't tell you it is what you use
it for i don't use it for anything
actually wow and what's that up there
that was here when i got here believe it
or not that's for sale
apparently so so he went onto the beach
picked up some driftwood and then dipped
it in some varnish
22 uh-huh stop same as that one over
there no
insane though
have you sold any of these
never
seriously and how much for the t-shirts
between 12 for employees and 18 for
guests so staff have to pay for their
own t-shirts yes and for the guests
they're 18 yes wow so when was the last
time you sold a t-shirt i sell them
every day but mostly to um the employees
the employees
yes how long have you been here
the establishment's been here almost
three years i've been here almost three
years as well what's wrong with it from
your point of view noise levels you know
especially the one directly above the
restaurant that what kind of
noise because it's not the the music and
the people the foot traffic everybody
hanging out at the bar and things of
that nature so that goes on directly
underneath yes
they end up being refunded and then they
end up putting us on blast on all of
these you know websites and social media
and just bad reviews left and right
housekeeping come back
what's that for touch base with the
housekeepers
wow
um just out of interest uh it's gordon
here i've just checked in how far away
are the [ __ ] rooms i mean
you sound like you're miles away
hello madam
and you scared her so room 16.
yes um where is it please nine i'm gonna
direct you right this way
what's that thing there we grill our
wings on it
you grill your wings on it yes how often
do you grill wings in there every
stinkin day
wow jesus in fact i think there's a wing
left in there
when was that grilled
chances are it could have been yesterday
those are the extra crispy ones
and who's responsible for this
the kitchen handles all of this end of
it of course you found another char
broiled and these were done yesterday i
believe so and they cook every day on
here yes i know the customer's still
alive
[ __ ]
right room 16.
this is your caribbean building the
caribbean
caribbean caribbean yes
what part of this resembles the
caribbean
i think it's more so because of the view
or the view
right here sir thank you very much
you're very welcome enjoy thank you
thank you
wow
look at this
wow
it stinks in here
there's a very
sort of damp musty smell bloody hell
oh
the bed feels like it's 15 years old
my
snails are terrible
the place is filthy
really bad
absolutely disgusting
180 dollars of eye for this [ __ ] oh
wow
many bar
consisting of absolutely [ __ ] all
freezer
over frozen and defrosted about 10 years
ago what a mess
[Music]
i know when i'm coming to fix a business
they have various issues
but right now with the information i
have i am not impressed with how brian
as an owner is operating this hotel
hello hello welcome to the inlet so you
must be brian i am sir the hotelier and
the
34 year old i do it all you do it all
is that what you are seriously 34
right
you know what i'm 33.
i work so hard i think i just thought i
was 34. you're studying three yeah yeah
um did you call this building the
caribbean
yes have you ever been to the caribbean
yeah which part uh lahamas and
this has been modeled on the bahamas
correct
do you smoke when you're in the bahamas
you know what that i've tried a couple
times surely stop yeah yeah
what hotel in the caribbean or the
bahamas were you running before you
bought this one so i've just visited the
caribbean i've never ran a hotel in the
caribbean so you just go buy yourself a
25 bedroom hotel on the beach with a
barn all i know how to do is run a fish
market when i open this and i filled it
from the scratch from the ground up so
the fish is fresh obviously from the
market they're so fresh right i better
jump in can i show you a table uh yes
why not yeah
table for you right here excellent thank
you yeah please
i'm excited for the fresh fish
this is so surreal bro gordon ridge in
the dining room what's with the main
tanks i mean you're the owner right i
think i should lead by example so i i i
like to wear mine that way if i tell
them that they need to wear them then
they can't say well brian you don't wear
yours right i'm starving i'm going to
get you some food right away i'm going
to get you a great server okay grace
how are you doing nice to see you guys
kelly kelly how long you been here um
i've been here about a year nice
and um why do the staff have to buy the
t-shirts um i don't i was never told
even our first shirts our name tags you
buy your name tag as well yeah
we have to pay like eight dollars never
seen that before
eight dollars a name tag twelve dollars
a t-shirt that's twenty dollars when we
come to [ __ ] work
wow
as i look at the menu i notice it's
absolutely massive
so i decided to order the chicken wings
which honestly i wasn't surprised when
they were dry
then i had the lobster mac and cheese
which technically isn't mac and cheese
because they used penne pasta but the
worst part of my lunch was the tuna
burger which i knew wasn't quite right
is that fresh
it is frozen oh it's frozen yes
hold on you said fish market fresh fish
daily
frozen fish fresh fish what's going on
we use frozen sometimes sure and you
have a fish market that you
buy from
yeah yup yeah
um i'm confused ever since about four
months ago everything was fresh
everything i ran up a little bit of a
bill with my brother so we cut back and
started ordering some of the frozen
stuff from some of the purveyors i mean
what's the feedback we get some negative
feedback
he hasn't had one nice thing to say i
know it's i'll blow to the ego but
you knew it was gonna be something
everything
um explain this monstrosity what in the
[ __ ] is going on here
this is our kiosk
an effort to have products for all sorts
of people so volleyball volleyballs uh
sick bags
how how busy is this how was it going i
honestly uh it doesn't do that good
how many beach towels have you sold not
too many beach styles all right show me
one all right here we go okay love to
see one please
what a [ __ ] disaster
we're on the beach we don't have towels
what is wrong with this picture how was
lunch
okay
okay it's not good enough
ah i thought we lost you
thank you very much whenever you're
ready to go to the beach whenever i'm
ready to go to the beach wow how much
you have in stock
one
you got it oh that's the one okay can
you charge that to my room please yes so
we're sold out now
yes yeah
wow
cheese
[Music]
at lunch i was very disappointed that
brian falsely advertises fresh fish on
his menu i want to learn more about how
involved he is as an owner during an
evening at the beachfront checking in
susan addison can i go ahead and start
you off with something to drink okay
all right
smoke him if you got him
okay man hey chef uh just give us a
little quick run through how the line
works well normally i run the pass an
expo chef i'll take care of this boom
boom boom
usually the passenger the saute guy and
then the fry guy
working with ben i
can't really tell you what he does
where's brian i don't know chef and
brian would just avoid them instead of
trying to get to the root of the problem
and i think that in itself is a problem
how long have we been here uh since last
december oh wow so you've been here a
long time yeah in your mind what do you
think the major problems are lack of
consistency as a matter of fact and lack
of structure yeah i saw that lunchtime
yeah i found out about the fish not
being so fresh how can you not sell
fresh fish when you're on the beach
that's our motto fresh fish
so how many of you think understand that
we're selling frozen fish they probably
don't
no because i don't think the servers are
telling them meanwhile the customers
disappear yeah thank you thank you brian
how many of these customers in tonight
know that you're serving frozen food
you know they don't really know how the
uh the market works so probably none of
them i don't know how the market works
they don't understand sorry how are you
how are you do you think we'll be
serving frozen food tonight or fresh
fish fresh fresh why fresh
well why don't you explain to him
tonight that you changed things four
months ago and we're not serving fresh
fish anymore we're serving frozen
man up so uh just a few months ago we
switched from some of our fresh products
to some frozen seafood products why
would you do that they're quality
products they just aren't the best the
quality that you would expect from you
know the pelican seafood market they're
quality frozen products
yeah it's a cost thing so when i come
out to somewhere like this
being on the beach of course i would
hope have fresh fish where is this
[ __ ] freezer it's around here
right down here gordon let's have a look
so this is the frozen bit here
what's that
frozen avocado
are we
not in florida
and you can't make fresh avocado
dude this is [ __ ]
where's your freezer
man walking
wow wow wow when was the last time you
were in here i come in here
once a week at least and i want to want
to you know
just kind of look around or whatever
what is this
wow
oh man
look at that the water's gone slimy
and you come in here once a week yeah
what is that
[Music]
oh boy
[ __ ] it how what is that
pina colada
colada
why it's like that i have no idea it's
festive it's it's off it's bubbling
[Music]
oh man
that's terrible [ __ ] trash please trash
james trash please now pina colada right
down the drain
by the bucket load in the walk-in fridge
i mean who in the hell operates like
this
gordon this is chef ben's job he's the
executive chef he's the executive chef
and you've made him that executive chef
ryan sure i did
how'd you feel now
what's that tuna burger that's from the
burger yes it is oh my god seriously
bacon it's gone and it's it's off fresh
produce on top of old produce moldy and
this one ribeye ribeye defrosting
what is this those are the smoked
grilled chicken wings before they go
onto the char grill oh my god and what
is in this one
you are kidding me
so underneath in that bucket is what
cooked product cooked chicken and on top
of it is what
it's raw
raw chicken on top of cooked chicken i
had them for lunch
i am at a [ __ ] loss
you know the best way out of this is
just to shut the place down
it's not an option for me
what's that in there ben those are
marinated chicken wings yeah to be
smoked underneath next box
those are
smoked rule number [ __ ] one
ben
i know chef i didn't do it
you know i turned my back for a minute
and this is the kind of [ __ ] that
happens i walked in and it was bedlam
[Music]
he's telling me this is your fault
you've got no idea i am at a absolute
[ __ ] loss
i can't work like this
this
is huge
you now are running a restaurant cross
contaminated
[Music]
joey yeah chef who's responsible for
this
um
we all are the the entire kitchen is
yeah rule number one
you can't put hot food in a [ __ ] walk
it doesn't even go together no not at
all nowhere near each other
i guarantee you when it was put in there
after i marinated it they weren't
shuffled
i can give you 12 more issues in there
that are bad i mean you are heading for
a [ __ ] massive disaster
i
i mean who the hell put them on top of
the the other ones everybody in here
knows better haven't you trained
everybody to know that i mean
all i'm getting right now is excuses
the kitchen needs direction from the
chef the staff need direction from the
owner and your buddies can someone come
up with a [ __ ] solution
i'm gonna go in 86 the wings sort it out
quickly
come on guys
86 wings someone put raw [ __ ] chicken
wings on top of coconuts it wasn't me
somebody else did it
86 wings is the only thing i can do
right now what the [ __ ] is going on i
was baffled and amazed the words out of
ben's mouth were oh i cleaned that
cooler regularly every day
[Music]
you want me to go in there and pull
everything out clean it that is not your
job to wipe the ass executive chef i i
know that
there were weeks he wouldn't show up
maybe three days a week
why didn't brian step up brian
he may be oblivious to some of this
stuff they've known each other since
they were young guys
this is crazy so ben goes awol brian
does nothing about it the place starts
falling apart
and then he just steps back in when he
wants probably much pretty much but if
this was your business you wouldn't
tolerate that
long time ago i was all for fun two
months ago so i mean
no excuse for that walk-in like that so
i'm sorry i i just couldn't hold that
anymore he doesn't he doesn't come to
work that's the reason why it looks like
that okay that is absolutely the reason
why
if he's here by 12 and he leaves by five
we're lucky
i'm just i'm not james is telling me the
truth i'm i'm i'm here to tell you the
truth you're not telling me this i
promise you i'm gonna tell you the truth
the only way to really truly identify a
chef before you even taste his food is
open up his walking that speaks volumes
for any chef he's a chef that's given up
and go through the motions
sometimes i feel that way we've been
through a lot i know he's got a lot on
his place he's incompetent and he's
taking your [ __ ] business down
you know i i don't think he's
incompetent
you're [ __ ] mad
and the sad thing is
that your staff and your management and
your team see it and you're the only
person
that doesn't know
what's going on
and this is the way you want to run your
business yeah
you do not need my help
[Music]
what's up party people
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
that's loud that music it is loud oh man
how are you doing yeah i just need a
little piece of quiet um you good
that's crazy no yes it is i mean it's
like the blind leading the blind in
there because there's no discipline
there i do know ben's checked out
brian's never checked in and uh they're
all blaming each other yeah i do know
there's no there's no discipline there's
no communication there's none of it no
what's the problem with him stepping up
and
dealing with issues maybe it has
something to do with the fact that he
he's not fully
um experienced in certain
departments no are they hosting concerts
are they uh is it a frat party hangout
is that a college i mean how can they
call themselves a hotel
that's that's the difference that's the
part that we need to try to separate and
i've been saying it for a while yeah um
i'm sorry excuse me good evening beach
front end liza speaking how can i help
you
hi lizelle we're in room 20 and um
there's a lot of dust and it smells like
smoke and uh my my friend here gloria's
having a really bad reaction she had to
take steroids and it's supposed to be a
non-smoking room
i'll be right with you
ryan those two guests have checked in
upstairs okay
uh she's uh she's got an issue with
analogy because everyone stinks of smoke
it'd be nice to just come up and see
them or try and count the situation now
so the lady's got an allergy and she's
already had to take a steroid and her
eyes are streaming and she's not very
happy okay
hello hello so are you okay oh yeah i'm
fine you sure any issues
oh water all over the floor sorry we had
water all over the floor water all over
the floor the refrigerator there's water
on the floor oh no really i just cleaned
it up with a towel yeah you still see
something i'm sorry
damn i walked down
it was completely all the way to the bed
wow
let's uh let's let's come back to school
well the ladies her eyes are streaming
do excuse us
ladies
are you decent
sorry i've got the owner here i think
we've figured out oh really the smell is
good
oh [ __ ]
there you go
it's just my eyes are tearing when was
that clean last that's a uh that's
really a daily thing that um daily it
should be sure yeah absolutely
that is not daily uh look at that
that's why
jesus christ almighty
now one of the poor ladies broken
out like the back of my throat is all
scratchy
is there an alternative room we can use
for ladies i'll double check right away
have a drink downstairs a little bite to
eat but we can sort something out okay
the big problem here is that there's no
direction for the hotel for the
restaurant for the gazebo not even for
the car park ben is like a headless
chicken that's checked out and brian's
like this scared school kid that
is not qualified to run a [ __ ] beach
bar let alone a hotel on a beach so
this is bad
this is really grim
[Music]
ryan
am i wrong i feel like we blew it
tonight oh man that's this is what it is
you know we'll uh don't worry about it
[Music]
oh my god say
after a very frustrating night i woke up
this morning hopeful that brian would be
eager to admit his faults at the
beachfront
but that wasn't the case
even after a staff meeting
none of the problems are sinking in with
brian so i reached out to his brother
eric who is continuing to fund the
business and i'm hoping brian can start
to see the damage he has done
hey what's up guys
thanks for coming in
why is ramsay here
your brother just asked you a question
why did you call me here i've got uh a
lot of issues that uh i need to take
care of you don't look like a man that's
in pain you don't look like a man that's
struggling you don't look like a man
that's lost control you look like you're
bouncing around having fun the business
is hurting you're hurting your brother's
business and you're not realizing it
it does reach a ceiling where where
brian you're gonna have to get cut off
i will i'll respect it but you gotta let
me know how much time and i'll i'll i'll
make it i'll make it
two more months but then that's it
months
here's my promise
i will focus so hard
and
i will be able to pay you in eight weeks
i'll pay you in eight weeks i'll pay in
eight weeks
thirty grand
you gotta you you you gotta give me you
gotta give me 90 days i mean you got to
give me 90 days
he's just giving you eight weeks you've
just asked for 12 weeks
you can't continue depending
on your little brother's cash
to float your dreams
i just need you to make sure not to
screw this one up again
i'm not gonna screw it
i'm not convinced
i'm not no no no you're lucky he's your
[ __ ] brother
eric i got you eight months eight weeks
eight weeks you're cut off that's all
there is to it man
how important is your reputation to you
that's the most important thing in my
world and on a scale of one to ten your
reputation in this town now i gave
myself a good a good eight a good eight
good get stronger absolutely
so these are customers that have gone
out their way to spend their hard-earned
cash supporting your business
you must recognize a few of these faces
absolutely i do let's start off with the
lady in the blue shirt you know her very
well hey play hi brian how do you know
each other uh i market brian you're a
spokesperson for that business yes can
you be honest with this one yes i can
the service is very
bad
i've brought people here i've been up at
the bar myself trying to order even just
a water that's been tough
do you not listen to the advice in terms
of sloppy service
i i absolutely i listen i do listen i do
listen i do listen do you offload that
to your team
no i don't i don't so that's why it's
not dealt with
sir your experience we ordered a chicken
sandwich when the chicken sandwich came
out it was raw
it was raw and it was mushy in the
middle i could have got sick from that
and i love your bar because i could come
here late night and i can get free
drinks two for me and two from my buddy
and pay for one we got five
wow
unbelievable so my first experience here
was a super bowl party that you
advertised and actually had some out of
town guests food was very mediocre the
crab cakes were like sawdust they were
horrible that night after the game was
over a couple rowdy fans started a
little brawl
uh we had drinks thrown on us
wow the other thing i'd like to say is
if i'm staying on the ocean i'd love to
fall asleep with the window open and
hear the ocean
you can't do that here you hear music
all night long
i honestly stayed here myself once
i tried to call down because um our
sheets were dirty you couldn't even call
like nobody answered and literally i
think the biggest
problem for me is the mixed message it's
like are you a bar or are you a
restaurant because you're paying 150 for
dinner however there's people walking in
in bikinis drunk
damn
listen this feedback has been crucial
anything you'd like to say
thank you guys you guys rock man thank
you thank you i'm telling you make you
proud i promise you
[Applause]
let's go
it's not a time for high-fiving you're
[ __ ] embarrassed what the [ __ ] you
hugging them for i know that they care i
do know they can i raw chicken sandwich
well that's not an eight
that is not an eight out of ten and do
you think they're set up do you think
this is a tv show and we're just gonna
spout off
these people aren't exaggerating they're
real they're real customers
you're turning into a laughing stock
yeah i know it's not good the jury's out
with me i've never come this far and
still sat on the fence in an undecided
way but [ __ ] listen up and listen
carefully
the partying the free-for-all i'm paying
for wondering they're giving me five
in front of your eyes
tomorrow
you turn up here looking like an owner
understood you got a lot on your plate
but get your head
out the [ __ ] clouds and get real
[ __ ] off i've got this gordon i'll show
you
even though i wasn't won over by brian's
commitment i went ahead and designed a
new concept for the beachfront
my team and i completely overhauled the
rooms and added a beach club to the
unused outdoor space
i'm really hoping brian can see the
potential he has to offer
good morning good morning well i wish it
was a good morning
why did i ask you to come
into work today what did i say was the
one thing i said to you come in as a
boss a boss
right now
you look like a towel boy
i mean sunglasses around your neck
badge on there shorts on there who are
you
give me the name badge
[Music]
stand out from the crowd you're the
owner
i've had a really rough night and so is
my team get out of here get changed and
come back like an owner now [ __ ] off
ready
honestly
hurry up no no no no no i'm not
listening
gordon
i'm coming back like a boss i'm ready to
make this whole fort pierce community
gordon get out of there
seat belt on
no doors and no seat belt
oh my god
[Music]
i'll be back i'll be back i'll be ready
[Music]
brian returned looking like an owner and
i'm hoping that translates into his role
as a boss let's go jerry quick step
let's go
it's time to reveal to brian and his
staff the newly renovated beachfront inn
and inlet oh my god wow
this is what i envisioned
wow wow first of all this is not the
spring break hangout that's gone wrong
this is a proper beachfront room sweet
oh yeah
oh yeah so inlet
oh my god whoa the floor i love it it's
it's perfect but you've got a tangible
asset here that can help lift this
business
and more importantly start making money
awesome brian you need to get a grip of
this business and you need to realize
you know what's at stake here i need to
be convinced i need to see you stepping
up as a boss ben and jerry we're
relaunching that russian tonight so i'm
gonna go through with that menu jump
downstairs get organized and start
finding your way let's go oh
man
after observing dinner service
i saw the beachfront kitchen wasn't set
up to handle such a massive menu
so i redesigned a smaller menu that is
easy for ben to
execute okay guys small menu let's run
from the top appetizers lobster mac and
cheese done with the correct pasta ben
steamed clams again great sharing for
the table wings off the smoker so it
stays nice and crisp
and a chicken cobb salad entrees pancake
scallops easy three says
ahi tuna fresh and then of course the
mahi mai it's small it's inviting and
tonight
i've just been told that we've got the
mayor in for dinner one person we can
reach out to to send the messages back
in the community this is it
dig in
that sauce is fabulous oh my god
wow
it's time to relaunch the beachfront
i've put a plan in place and i'm really
hoping brian can finally show me that
he's ready to run his business all right
everybody
listen up
tonight is a big service there's not
many opportunities like this
you have to take advantage of it i need
you guys all to get together right now
and bring it in one two three
brian
ryan let's just get real for a couple of
seconds yeah yes sir you forgot the
[ __ ] most important thing tonight
who is in for dinner tonight you haven't
even told the staff possibly the most
important person in this town we have
the mayor in the night the mayor and
that's just not something that happens
every [ __ ] week you have to bring it
together tonight you have to work as a
team
sort it out guys we're opening in five
minutes
come on
[Music]
checking in
all right
welcome to the inlet good evening good
evening this is lovely um enjoy dinner
an amazing array of appetizers and the
entrees are to die for taurus in the
hair slow steady wins the race
so first take it on yes
good
hi how are you welcome hey guys
it's the mayor okay
yeah that's the man now why are you
sitting here
come on where well they were gonna they
were gonna give her a choice we'd like
to sit inside and outside it's her
choice
welcome
how are you thank you for coming in
thank you guys likewise um it's an
absolute pleasure i'll leave you in
hands of our manager owner brian follow
me guys welcome hi so much good to see
you sir likewise
okay guys
all right mayor wherever you like inside
i got a chicken burger ready at your
leisure
chicken burger
ben as brian told you the amazing no no
he has not
unreal
brian
your chef doesn't even know the mayor's
in
ah
you don't think he deserves to know
because he does come on man ben yes the
mayor's in at table seven her table set
inside
am i good ben
i've got that blackened chicken for you
and that's it
ben you need to be the captain and right
now
i'm not convinced let's get serious
about this business and do this is the
mayor's order in
are they sending appetizers yet
are they are they at the table no i put
their food in he wanted the salad in the
fried calamari and she wanted the uh
mahi okay great so again check it that's
your hot ticket tonight but do you know
what's happening in your kitchen at the
moment
no look at me do you know what's
happening in there you haven't got a
[ __ ] clue yeah get into the kitchen
find out what's going on let's go
behind you
ow that burned my forehead
so what did you guys order
um i got the mahi-mahi and a salad and
he got an appetizer
the mayor is the only person sat with
nothing in front of her
please
all right two tunas
can i have table 15's appetizers asap
it's the mayor
15 15. i was told seven [ __ ] man
sorry miss communications they're set on
15 right i made a mistake it's 50. okay
i need two house salads right now before
anything else right in a second
brian didn't know what table the mayor
was at
it seems like the biggest thing brian
changed was his wardrobe two houses are
in the window two houses need to go 15.
have you seen the salads yeah
ben yes you need to see that you need to
taste that and see everything he's doing
there terry that's too much dressing bro
redo it sala's overdressed soggy as [ __ ]
wrong dressing
yes sir what i need to hear is a bit of
a voice if we go silent we'll go down
[Music]
tonight's relaunch of the beachfront
sala's overdressed soggy as [ __ ] wrong
dressing
i was really hoping brian would step up
as an owner given that i put everything
in place for him to succeed
[Music]
but his lack of focus has me really
worried that he's not fit to run this
place come on brian ben bye
right now come here
come here let's go your chef was shut
down
i didn't realize that you didn't realize
so the first two sellers for the mayor
had the wrong dressing on and were
overdressed i said if he tasted them he
said no
so he hasn't got your back when's that
penny gonna drop that you're gonna turn
the corner
i will watch ben if he doesn't come out
of it we'll switch him and joey will you
how many guacamoles you guys got out
there
okay
okay
give me time on the mayor's table please
ben
table 15. yeah the mayor's table we sold
it calamari and uh mahi
did you see it before it went i sure did
i played at everything
the mayor hasn't got a [ __ ] excuse
brian brian urgently come here
so ben's told me the [ __ ] mayor's got
their food
and look at the nurse table
there's nothing on there look at me look
look no hey we're about to go down yeah
and i'm gonna get in my [ __ ] car and
i get to [ __ ] out of it if you don't get
a grip
because this is a [ __ ] joke now you
better get in there and tell your
executive chef then that the mayor
hasn't got their food and find out where
the [ __ ] it is
ben the mayor has not gotten her food
i'll put it in the window where where
should i make it right now i'll make it
right now
[Applause]
be nice to have some food right about
here let's try the mayor's food again
terry i need a caesar now it's coming
right now tina
quarter out
where's that going
51. 51. where are you
what is that
that is undercooked
uh young lady come here
what does that chicken look like to you
thank you so it's dry
um
lady how would you describe that chicken
it looks kind of dry very dry okay guys
you're not even a chef are you no no
how old are you i'm 20. 20. thanks
darling so from a 20 year old server
that's never cooked even spotting is dry
and you're saying it's raw
let me tell you something and listen
carefully
i'm going
i'm packing my bags because that is the
worst thing we've sent all week it's
overcooked and it's dry and then you
you tell me it's raw
good night
i'm done
[Music]
that
is unreal i mean i'm so pissed off
i can't
give that guy
any more advice i can't
continue to tell him to step up and make
decisions
he has a chef in there that's just
riding him
and riding the business and when you're
weak
you've got no chance of running a
business
and
what a shame
i'm
[ __ ] real
[Music]
i never liked to leave a business but
brian simply wasn't listening
he missed the deadline paying his
brother back
and while it's been a slow process my
advice finally started to sink in
four months after i left he made a
decision to let chef ben go and hired a
brand new kitchen staff on the hotel
side brian has made the guest a priority
given the curfew to the nighttime
entertainment
hopefully now with brian stepping up
like a boss he can lead the beachfront
in the right direction
you